i think a trick
for most people that might benefit them
is just be cognizant of how much content
you're consuming
and try to make sure that you're
creating more content than you're
consuming yeah
yes because you can replace content with
whatever it is that's getting you closer
to your goals right it's too easy for
you to have
your creativity done for you
yeah and it's just you know if i find my
even and you know i've got a youtube
channel on macroeconomics but if i find
myself uh listening to four hours of
podcasts and only doing a half an hour
video that that's that's not good i want
to make sure that okay if i'm listening
to four hours of content that how am i
going to create five hours of content
based on what i listen to to make sure
you're always
ahead of that curve and you're not
falling victim to just uh
just i i
don't want to say being a loser but uh
you know not achieving your goals as
quickly as you could what does kiyosaki
say is if you're not a brand you're a
commodity
i haven't heard him say that but that
sounds like something that probably
sounds like something well it's kind of
like one of the things i always say
george is and it kind of goes to
you know i i enjoy simplifying things
you said hey is it cheap or is expensive
you know it's very easy to answer that
so what i do you know the the greatest
commodity in life is time right we you
know so what i um
what i always say is you can either
invest your time or you can spend your
time
in the in my 20s i was the king of
spending my time
nightclubs games fantasy football
partying drunk you know just spending
time you're a party boy party i was a
party boy no man not a party man yet i'm
very conscious of investing my time
versus spending my time very rarely am i
just
spending i don't have netflix i canceled
it i i pulled the plug i don't have
enough tv anymore if i watch youtube
it's because i want to watch what george
gammon has to say on the economy or what
rolo tomasi has to say on transgenderism
or what fresh and fit have to say with
their drama that's going on or what's
going on in the news i'm investing my
time because you talked about always be
learning always be learning and you can
spend your time like i look i've watched
game of thrones i had a girlfriend she
wanted to watch it i get it so you're
not going to all these hours
i think people but it's a lot of time i
think people can use that as a hack in
other areas of their life that they
might not even think about especially as
americans
so let me give you an example um prior
to 2019 even though i would spend a lot
of time in medellin i never considered
having a a gal do the cooking you know
cook and have someone specific to do my
laundry and make sure that the closet
was organized if i need a light bulb go
it just some seemed like an extravagance
that i just didn't you know george how
hard is it to change a light bulb
but then what i did is i actually did a
tv show in medellin early 2019 before i
started the youtube channel so i was
taking this was occupying so much of my
time that i just didn't have a choice so
i'm like i've got to hire someone to do
the cooking and all these things
and i had this gal for probably two
weeks
and i said how did i ever live without
this
and i think you know now that when i
come back to the united states
and i don't have that team of people
with me right that entourage that i have
that i have in medellin you know i've
got to go get my own water i've got to
go and and
we don't even think about that as
americans but if you actually wrote down
every single minute you spend during the
week taking your kids to school going to
the grocery store picking up the dry
cleaning running an errand dude this
this and this it's like 10 20 hours a
week
when that's 20 hours that you could
spend on doing something incredibly
productive well it comes down to george
you you hit the nail on the head just as
you've been doing all day today
what's your time worth that's right
what's your time worth patrick talks
about like how he loves to iron like i
no chance of my ironing like
like nor would i no but he lo but he
said look my time is worth
a thousand dollars an hour that's right
and for me to iron for an hour i could
pay someone 20 an hour to do that i'm
losing 980 dollars
by ironing and then you just gotta back
into what you're doing in your life now
look not everybody's gonna always have a
maid and someone to iron and cook and
clean i get it but what can you
eliminate from your life yeah to take
back
look i got a question do you feel like
you've been put out like if you like
watch a football game or you like went
to watch a movie or something god look i
could have made it was two hours to
watch this movie
could i have made more money like would
have been time better spent i don't get
that two hours back so
i feel bad about having like sort of
having this mental popcorn and just sort
of like enjoying you're enjoying the
movie you like the movie right it's good
to like you know have some power down
time but it's like
i cuz i get to the point like the more i
get into doing like you know doing what
i do i'm like i gotta write another
chapter in the book so if you like that
clip click right here to watch another
or if you want to watch the entire sauce
cast click right here
[Music]